la chronique de l'innovation sofival a
choisi de nous parler aujourd'hui des
imprimantes 3d comment fonctionne-t-elle
et surtout à quoi servent tel mode
d'emploi et précision avec ce reportage
c'est une petite révolution qui arrivent
dans nos salons les imprimantes 3d
imaginez que vous soyez capable de
fabriquer vous même de petits objets en
plastique à partir d'une simple machine
reliée à un ordinateur alors pour
l'instant ce sont surtout des passionnés
et des bricoleurs qui essayent de
maîtriser cet outil aussi des
informaticiens comme ici attrape alors
jonathan boussouar merci de nous
recevoir ici dans votre bureau alors
qu'est-ce que vous imprimez aujourd'hui
alors aujourd'hui j'ai imprimé un petit
sifflet que j'ai récupéré sur un site de
partage d'objets vous allez fabriquer ce
sifflet avec cette machine oui tout à
fait combien de temps ça va mettre le
sifflet il va mettre 30 36 minutes est
un plus mais comment ça fonctionne là
exactement on peut décrire les
différentes parties de la machine oui
donc on vient chauffer du plastique
c'est un peu le même principe qu'un
pistolet à colle donc où on chauffe du
plastique on le passe à part la dernière
d'une buse une petite tête à tête et on
vient d'opposer par couches successives
du fils fondu et au fur et à mesure on
peut construire un objet en 3d voilà
vraiment couche par couche par couche at
on a les trois dimensions on peut
fabriquer plein de choses vous vous avez
déjà fabriqué un certain nombre de
choses g
j'ai cassé un petit objet
c'est une barbe pour mon volets roulants
donc c'est le support de la barre et ben
je vais recruter alors dit si j'avais
réparer un jeu les modéliser sur
l'ordinateur ça m'a pris mon genou
modéliser ça veut dire que vous créez un
plan un plan la dimension et après 17
heures j'ai fait et je les crée bagelet
imprimés donc cet objet magie est
imprégné en une heure et puis il ya
aussi des gens qui vous font des petites
commandes dans votre famille par exemple
vous vous titiller oui bah voila j'ai
pour
le fils d'une amie moi j'ai récupéré un
objet qui indique camions en 3d imprimé
en une seule fois avec les articulations
et les roues qui bouge
alors tout à l'heure vous me disiez
c'est moi qui ai fait le plan c'est vrai
que c'est pas forcément évident pour
tout le monde il faut savoir utiliser un
logiciel de modélisation il faut passer
un peu de temps
il ya des tutoz sur internet d
en même temps vidéo et donc ça prend du
temps au départ mais après ça devient
facile et puis sinon sinon c'est pas
modéliser donc on va sur internet il ya
des sites qui donnent accès à les plans
voilà il ya des le site de partage
d'objets donc il ya des d'autres
personnes qu'ils ont créée par exemple
d'autres objets similaires et quand on
sait pas dessiner on peut lui récupère
et on peut les imprimer ça c'est gratuit
ça c'est gratuit pourquoi c'est le
principe du partage c'est un peu la
logique de la machine le partage tout
est en accès libre
voilà un peu bas tout fonctionne sous
linux moi je suis sous linux aussi donc
tous les logiciels sont en open source
en libre d'accès tout le monde peut
l'utiliser
alors ça donne l'impression qu'il ya
effectivement une petite révolution
parce que on peut créer soi-même plein
de petites choses est-ce que c'est par
exemple la fin de l'obsolescence
programmée le fait que nos objets de ska
par maintenant on va pouvoir les réparer
oui on peut on peut les réparer oui
justement ce sera c'est un peu une
petite révolution mais c'est une
révolution il ya dans le domaine de
l'industrie sa devise la machine 3 des
églises depuis plusieurs dizaines
d'années mais maintenant elle et devient
accessible aux particuliers pour ceux
qui veulent brûler grassin
des petits kits de la fabrique grâce à
un prof britannique qui a mis
cette imprimante 3d en libre de droit
donc il ya toute une communauté qui
maintenant utiliser
la modif il améliore et si on n'est pas
très très bricoleur mais que quand même
ça nous intéresse combien ça coûte une
machine comme ça
en kit il faut compter à peu près 500
euros voilà maintenant il m'a si la
machine montée il faut compter le double
1000 euros on a une bonne main entre 800
et 900 euros combien de temps ça met à
fabriquer si on la fabrique soi-même
vous vous lavez fabriquer vous-même ya
quelques mois oui c'est ça cet hiver
j'ai donc bah j'ai plusieurs soirées
plusieurs week-ends
donc à lire aussi toute la documentation
qui est disponible sur internet
commencé à prendre des contacts avec
d'autres personnes qui l'ont construit
une ou qui sont en train de reconstruire
une pour avoir des renseignements qui au
départ c'est pas évident et au fur à
mesure
bombardier moi j'avais bon je pense que
j'ai passé deux mois
avec quelques heures le soir quelques
heures le week end qu'est ce qui vous
plaît vous là dedans dans cette machine
bah là
de pouvoir réaliser quelque chose de soi
même et quand même temps ça me permet de
découvrir toute la partie
mécanique partie informatique la partie
bombée une journée que je connais déjà à
mon métier mais donc voilà on m'a permis
de
de m'ouvrir sur d'autres horizons c'est
ludique aussi voilà c'est mérité
pratique alors nous on a fait un petit
test on vous a demandé si vous pouviez
reproduire notre cash micro alors est-ce
que vous pouvez nous montrer ce que vous
avez réussi à faire alors je dessinais
je
les rôles 13e les mots glissés mobilisés
pas tout à fait encore bien réglé parce
qu'ils aient des petites craquelures qui
sont apparues à la fin de l'objet du aux
contraintes du plastique que je que je
ne maîtrise pas encore mais on n'est pas
mal quand même
bon j'ai peut-être fait dû faire les
alors on vit un peu plus grand mais bon
ça c'est parce que vous avez réussi à
faire un plan de l'emploi désir de cet
objet là et alors vous me disiez il est
pas tout à fait parfait parce que voilà
la machine c'est aussi on fait des
essais il ya des échecs on recommence
voilà on apprend de nos erreurs et puis
bah comme jeu ben je ne maîtrise pas
encore tous je fais partie d'une
association
à ris orangis
la planète sciences et ça m'a permis de
rencontrer pas mal de gens de discuter
de 2
de faire un partage d'informations et
comme ça ça nous permet de progresser
d'avancer tous ensemble une petite
communauté à 50 ans vous ça met du temps
à se mettre à saint-quentin non j'ai
peur j'ai trouvé encore personne
voilà sur paris sur paris il ya pas mal
de personnes et
voilà c'est vrai que l'on vient on fait
tous à peu près 50 kilomètres pour se
réunir
pour justement essayer de partager et
surtout de s'entraîner et ben merci
beaucoup je remercie de nous avoir
expliqué tout ça
avis aux amateurs et puis viendront nous
rejoindre éventuellement oui
sophy bonsoir justement vous êtes venu
avec quelques-uns de ces objets juste
avant que vous nous expliquer encore
deux trois choses autour de cette
imprimante 3d bonsoir également à
nourrir est inouï ce merci d'être venu
sur ce plateau assouma ya également du
collège de la géo qui remet en prix en
qui remet en jeu son prix du trophée
d'improvisation puisque c'est cette
compétition d'un pro qui se déroule
demain la finale à la verrière qui va
nous intéresser dans un instant pour
l'instant soyez attentifs on continue à
parler de l'imprimante 3d avec sophie
tout à fait donc je vous ai
effectivement amener des petits objets
qui ont été fabriqués par jonathan bout
ce soir le cash micro qu'on lui a
demandé de faire ce que ces souliers de
nice est le premier de presse voulait
tester si les soucis des fours 1 on voit
que voilà ça commence d'accès parfois
j'observe qu'il ya des petits trous mais
voilà c'est que ça marche pas du premier
coup il faut faire plusieurs et fabas
s'est cassé
voilà pour la mauvaise blague pour elsa
que j'ai fait mon patrice carmouze
j'ai également amené un petit objet un
jouet qui l'a fabriqué également
lui-même il a pris les plans sur
internet parce qu'on peut trouver des
plans sur internet donc c'est un petit
camion puis alors il est quand même
c'est pas sur le territoire à l'image il
est quand même assez fin et puis il est
fait de plusieurs plusieurs morceaux ici
on peut soulever la heureusement par
exemple avec et les rues roule
effectivement des rovers joue bien ça ça
tourne ça tourne c'est ce que je voulais
dire c'est que c'était assez à ses fins
quand même très bien j'ai ramené le
petit il est également un qui marche
non mais c'est dangereux aliénés
peut-être pour l'arbitré compétition
d'impro justement voilà
et puis et puis j'ai ramené au 6 qui ne
montre pas c'est que on lui demande
parfois de réparer des objets d'assez
son papa qui lui a demandé de refaire
ici on voit un objet qu'on lui a demandé
de faire c'est la poignée des portes de
placards de la cuisine de son papa est
donc lui là il a refait vous voyez à
l'identique on le voit l'image alors là
ça sert à des particuliers c'est très
répandue ou 7 pouces pour les
professionnels alors effectivement les
professionnels l'utilisé déjà avant il
ya quelques temps les utiliser même des
grosses machines les particuliers ou en
mode est plus petit ça sert en fait
quand on le fait en tant qu'industriel à
faire des prototypes avant de lancer une
production à grande échelle est donc
aujourd'hui c'est pratique ces petites
machines par exemple pour les auto
entrepreneurs puisque vous pouvez vous
lancer en achetant cette machine qui
coûte pas bien cher de bonne qualité
vous pouvez en avoir une pour 1000 euros
petit investissement déclenchée quand on
est professionnel c'est par sa maman le
gros investissement et puis ensuite dans
le plastique ça coûte pas très cher
quelques euros pour tous les filaments
plastique qu'on a pu voir dans le
reportage donc donc c'est que satisfaire
ce dans différents domaines tout ça sert
dans les fermes appliquaient domaines
par exemple eads la maison mère d'airbus
est vrai que ses avions avec des
imprimantes
mais justement ils ont décidé de se
lancer là dedans pour la fabrication des
différentes parties de l'avion avec zéro
seront entre dimension il ya aussi
d'autres utilisations qui sont parfois
plus surprenantes voire un petit peu
gênante du point de vue éthique je peux
si vous avez entendu parler il ya
quelques temps aux pays bas ils ont
décidé de se lancer dans la fabrication
de viande artificielle est bien avec
cette machine ils ont créé des steaks
artificiel eh oui
mais ça pourrait faire une bonne
thématiques et des steaks blanc aussi
que parce que j'ai imposant que tout est
vrai pardon on peut faire plusieurs
couleurs n'avait pas acheté la carte aux
couleurs pour aller avec ses cols blancs
bon en dehors de cette utilisation un
peu insolite oui jean-claude s'annonce
que c'est quand même une troisième
révolution industrielle parce que bat
tout le monde peut créer des objets chez
soi et ça va peut-être permettre de re
localiser la production qui avait été
auparavant délocalisent
voilà je vais l'enlever complètement
voilà sur soi sur même barack obama s'y
intéressent absolument dans la kobama en
février la dernier il disait dans un
discours qui voulait que l'amérique
investissent grandement dans la création
des centres d'impression 3d pour
relancer l'innovation et la création
d'emplois alors forcément d'une bonne
idée mais c'est toujours la même
mauvaise idée il ya des mauvaises
utilisations aussi voilà il ya eu le
scandale il ya quelques semaines ce
n'est pas cette personne sans merci
c'est un petit peu un petit peu gaffe
quand même d une association américaine
qui a créé de toutes pièces une arme à
feu et qui en plus a mis les plans en
ligne donc évidemment il ya des dérives
comme dans toutes les innovations il va
falloir que la loi encadre cette
nouvelle machine dont la limite est à
l'utilisation de la confection de
poignées de portes de cuisine va là pour
son beau père ça fonctionne mieux c'est
mieux comme ça qu'une arme à feu voilà
pour cette chronique innovation une info
juste heures en plus pour terminer une
info en plus le prestigieux prix gödel
vous ne le connaissez peut-être pas mais
il récompense des travaux remarquables
en informatique théorique ça a lieu à
palo alto en californie
et si je vous en parle c'est parce que
le 3 juin dernier il a été attribué un
chercheur du laboratoire prisme de l'ue
vs qu l'université de saint quentin en
yvelines et c'est antoine joue qu'on
voit sur cette photo qui l'a reçu il a
élaboré avec deux autres scientifiques
américains un système de calcul
innovants dans le domaine de la
cryptographie qu'est ce que c'est la
cryptographie c'est le domaine de la
protection des données et des messages
c'est une découverte qui peut avoir pour
applications par exemple celle de
permettre de retrouver parmi les abonnés
à une chaîne cryptée celui qui a revendu
illégalement ces vidéos à d'autres
utilisateurs
sophie voilà merci ce fut pour celle du
tarn bah oui c'est très très forcément
très très utile merci je dis ça c'est
pas gentil pour chercheurs ce cynisme
pour la boutade voilà c'est très
important de faire des recherches merci
sophy on en trouve la semaine prochaine
pour une nouvelle chronique